♪♪ YOU KNOW I LOVE YOU ♪
♪ I'LL ALWAYS BE TRUE ♪
♪ SO PLEASE ♪♪
>> Greg: HYPOCRISY FROM THE
CORRUPT DEMOCRATS WHO RULE OVER
CHICAGO.
UP 29%, CRIME.
THE MAIRE, LORI LIGHTFOOT, CAN
SLEEP SOUNDLY THANKS TO HER
SECRET ARMY OF COPS.
SOME THE OFFICERS REPORTEDLY
CREATED TO KEEP THE MAYOR SAFE.
SHE ALREADY HAS.
THIS IS REALLY RICH, CONSIDERING
LIGHTFOOT WAS A MAJOR ADVOCATE
FOR CUTTING FUNDING TO POLICE.
>> Mayor Lightfoot: IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT TAKE ACCOUNTABILITY
IN THE WAY HAS ALIENATED PEOPLE
OF COLOR, PARTICULARLY
AFRICAN-AMERICANS IN THIS CITY.
WE LIVE IN A CITY THAT IS
TRAUMATIZED BY POLICE
MISCONDUCT.
>> Greg: WHY WOULD YOU NEED SOME
DEEP OFFICERS TO PROTECT SOMEONE
LIKE THAT?
>> I'M GOING TO SHOCK YOU.
I HAVE SPOKEN TO TWO RATHER THAN
IF YOU GET HIGH-LEVEL PEOPLE IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
AND THEY TOLD ME WHAT I DID NOT
EXPECT I WOULD BE SAYING.
AND THAT IS THAT THE NUMBER 71
IS NOT THAT UNUSUAL BECAUSE YOU
HAVE GOT 24/7 OPERATION AND SO
IT IS AROUND-THE-CLOCK AND YOU
HAVE ALSO GOT THE MAYOR'S HOUSE
FOR SECURITY DETAIL AND CITY
HALL.
SO IF YOU THINK ABOUT THAT, THAT
IS A LOT OF PEOPLE FIND.
-- FINE.
I THINK WHAT SHE HAS DONE IS
TERRIBLE.
HER JOB.
INSTEAD OF BLAMING THE POLICE
AND SINK THE CITY OF CHICAGO IS
TRAUMATIZED BECAUSE OF THE
POLICE, SHE SHOULD KNOW FROM HER
OWN STATISTICS THAT WHEN SHE
STOPPED DEFUNDING THE POLICE AND
DECIDED TO SOMEWHAT UP THE
BUDGET FROM NOT TO WHERE IT WAS
BUT A LITTLE BIT FROM WHERE SHE
DEFUNDED IT, CRIME START TO GO
DOWN A TEENY BIT.
SHE UNDERSTANDS THAT POLICE ON
THE STREET ARE WHAT STOPS CRIME.
AND SO SHE HAS A RIGHT TO HAVE
HER OWN SECURITY DETAIL.
I HAD A SECURITY DETAIL WHEN I
WAS A.
IT IS SERIOUS BUSINESS AND ONLY
THEY KNOW WHAT IS APPROPRIATE.
>> IT IS EASY TO TALK ABOUT
DEFUNDING THE POLICE WHAT YOU
HAVE GOT YOUR OWN BRIGADES,
RIGHT?
THIS IS MY -- EXACTLY TV HOUSE
TALKING ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT
SHUTDOWNS WERE.
SHE NEVER HAD TO DEAL WITH THE
CONSEQUENCES.
SHE NEVER HAD TO TALKED TO THE
VICTIMS OR WORRY ABOUT CRIME
BECAUSE IT DID NOT TOUCH HER.
THEY HAVE TO BE STRIPPED OF THIS
STUFF BUT THE MOMENT THAT THEY
SAY THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
DEFUND SOMETHING, THEY SHOULD BE
STRIPPED OF IT IMMEDIATELY
BECAUSE THEY GOT A LIST.
THEY SHOULD WALK THE WALK.
>> THE QUESTION IS, IS SIMPLY
ONE APPROPRIATE FOR THE MAYOR'S
OFFICE AND YOUR PERSONAL DETAIL
PUT THE ANSWER IS YES.
PEOPLE LIKE CORI BUSH, WE WANT
TO DEFUND THE POLICE.
AND YET, YOU ARE SPENDING $200 A
YEAR.
IT IS WRONG.
>> JOE BIDEN IS DEFENSIVE.
WE HAVE THROWN A LOT OF MONEY ON
THE ISSUE.
I'M NOT SURE IF HE HAD A NO
CARD.
>> IS ANY OF IT RELATED TO
POLITICAL PRESSURE FROM
DEMOCRATS?
ARE DUE WHEN I FIRST GOT LIKE
TO, I WAS BEAT UP BECAUSE I
SUPPORTED THE POLICE TOO MUCH.
NO.
WHAT THAT IS WHAT I THINK.
>> NO.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I THINK THAT IS WHAT HE
THINKS.
HE HAS PUT THIS IN THE BUDGET.
HIS POLITICAL PROBLEMS ARE NOT
NECESSARILY ON THE RIGHT OR IN
THAT CENTER.
HIS PROBLEMS ARE ON THE LEFT.
DO YOU REMEMBER WHAT ALEXANDRA
CAUSEY CORTES SAID?
NOBODY ON THE LEFT IS ENERGIZED
BY HIM.
AND THEY ARE ABOUT YOUR BASED.
HE PUT INTO BILLIONAIRES
TECHNIC.
IT PROBABLY WON'T GO ANYWHERE
AND IT WAS EASY FOR HIM TO SAY,
GIVE MORE MONEY TO POLICE.
OTHER PEOPLE ON HIS LEFT DON'T
BELIEVE IT.
>> YOU WENT OUT ON THE SEGMENT.
WERE YOU ASSAULTED IMMEDIATELY
UPON LEAVING THE BUILDING BY ALL
OF THE PEOPLE IN NEW YORK CITY?
>> Piers: I WAS CELEBRATED.
THIS REMINDS ME OF THE WORST
POLITICAL SLOGAN IMAGINABLE.
99% OF PEOPLE.
POLITICALLY, IT IS A COMPLETE
FIASCO.
IF THERE'S ONE THING.
DOES NOT MATTER WHERE YOU ARE IN
THE WORLD, GUARANTEED TO ENRAGE
AN ELECTRIC, IT IS LIKE TO
OFFICIALS PREACHING ONE THING
AND DOING THE COMPLETE OPPOSITE
AND WE HAVE A VERY INTERESTING
CASE WITH PARTY GATE WHERE THE
PRIME MINISTER, THE ENTIRE STAFF
HAVING ANNOUNCED THE LOCKDOWN
RULES FOR THE COUNTRY AND VERY
DRACONIAN RESTRICTIONS.
IT TURNS OUT THEY WERE PARTYING,
BREAKING THEIR OWN RESTRICTIONS
EVERY SINGLE WEEK.
20 OF THEM THE FIND.
IT MAY INCLUDE BORIS JOHNSON.
BUT THE RAGE IS NOT ABOUT THE
FACT THEY WERE HAVING PARTIES
AND THAT RAGE ABOUT THIS IS NOT
THE -- THAT MAYOR LIGHTFOOT.
THE RAGE IS THE HYPOCRISY.
I WOULD LIKE TO DEFUND HYPOCRISY
BECAUSE THAT IS A CORROSIVE
THING FOR ANY LIKE TO OFFICIAL.
AFFECT THE SHE WAS OUT.
WE DON'T NEED MANY PLEASE.
ACTUALLY, I DO.
YOU DON'T.
YOU CAN ALL SUFFER THE CRIME.
IF MY YOUNGEST SON IS IN
UNIVERSITY IN CHICAGO AND HE
SAYS IT IS IT SCARY.
THAT IS THE BEST THINK ABOUT
BEING IN CHICAGO.
-- THING ABOUT BEING IN CHICAGO.
>> TORRAS' HAIR.
I HAVE SEEN HIM DO THIS.
AND IT WAS ALL STRAIGHT WHEN HE
ARRIVED.
I WATCHED HIM LOOK AROUND LIKE
THAT AND THEN RUFFLE IT UP.
IT IS COMPLETELY DELIBERATE.
>> HE THINKS -- JUST.
SLIGHTLY WILD.
>> MAKING HIS HEAD LOOKED L